This is a bit of a tricky question, so let's go over the first one first
and let's go back and take a look at the code.
So, most of these are arithmetic operations and if you remember from the RAM model that we've
been discussing in the lecture that according to the RAM model that we've been using,
all arithmetic operations take constant time, so it means this, this, this, and this all take constant time.
The only thing that doesn't is this for loop right here. So how many times does the for loop execute?
Well, that executes based on n, the value of the input about square root of n times
and if everything else is constant time and this executes square root of n times,
well from around the order the square root of n.
You can go ahead and check this.
So this next part is very pretty tricky and it hinges on getting this part right.
So if you have trouble with this, that is totally understandable.
So first, let's remember that we can represent n
with a logarithm and number of digits which is what d is.
What this means is that n=c where c is just some constant that we're not going by * 10⁻¹
and as an example of this, let's say, that n is 4000 like we had before.
So 4000=c where c is something * 10d⁻¹, d is 4-1 is ³,
and well then that means that this has to be 4, 4*10³ is 4000.
So this is how it represent an n by d and c is just some constant to make everything more count
and since this is big O equation, we're not really that concerned with constants.
Now, if we know this and we also know that the algorithm
has a running time from the order of square root of n, and we're talking about it in terms of n,
and then we can put these together, so square root of n is the square root of all this
and we're going to have to do a bit of math here.
Well, we can separate this two out to the √c and √10d⁻¹,
well we can describe this by saying this, 10d⁻¹/2 since that's exactly that the square root is.
And now we can pull this out and so now we have this nice three separate terms,
and again since we don't really care about constants, we can just kind of get rid of these.
We can say that √c * 10⁻¹/² is just some other constant we don't really care about code k.
Because the only thing we really care about is D.
So this is k * 10d/² and this is exactly what we need to say
but this algorithm is in big O notation until we can say that in terms of d
the running time in this algorithm is 0(10d/2).
Now, if you didn't get that or if you had problems with it,
don't worry about that it's really kind of a challenging problem
and if you still don't understand it,then I recommend checking on the forms and discussing it.
This is really the kind of basic math calculations that you're going to have to do
and part of the problem here that a lot of people run into is
these constants that we just drop or don't care about really
and that's the kind of thing that makes big O notation really very powerful
that we can just drop those and say we don't really care about those in the grand scheme of things.